I've been training my whole life I just
came for the free wine
[Music]
love Hawaiian I wouldn't say I'm an
expert but I drink a lot I used to be a
big Francia guy in college it's just the
best bang for your buck and it really
appeals to my cheap sensibilities I
figured out what tannins are and what
they taste like so I feel like pretty
cool I think that like the harder you
like it's like the more expertise you
are yeah this one's pretty sweet grapy
does smell like grapes I'm picking that
up too maybe it's made from grapes that
refined palates you and I there's a
little sweet mm-hmm I like that Oh oh my
god no no it's like smoky that's
straight-up like just juice that's grape
juice
[Music]
sounds like a Pinot Grigio I'd say that
is so sweet
it's extremely sweet sugar yeah yeah I
feel like Moscato is the one where you
like drinkin you're like this isn't
using anything and then this morning you
like can't feel your head I'm getting a
little warm I know that wine has ever
made me feel this way before God one of
these is more alcohol content than the
other huh
this one's sweeter yeah for sure sweetie
and that's where that sugar confounding
variable comes in because it could be
that the alcohols more masked by the
sugar here and it actually is more
alcoholic red woman yeah just like I
felt it in yeah it was like you know
like you like felt it going down I say
this one has more and this one has less
ready 1 2 3
I'm gonna say there's no alcohol with
either of these I'm gonna say don't put
me like that
[Music]
they don't damn oh I was starting to
feel warm though like I drank I was even
an option to be fair I thought she was
going ro oh so gross yeah that's why
there weren't any legs on the glass I
think if you've tasted wine before like
real wine before in the past this will
not cut it for you unfortunately I don't
really see the point if I want a juicy
juice I'll just drink the juice hmph
I mean there are times like I go out and
I want to like have a fancy drink but I
don't actually want to have alcohol so
it'd be nice if bars had like a juice
option
so that I couldn't feel like I was
participating unless you're like a child
chef and you want to like pair wine with
your pasta and I don't see really the
application but for our alcoholics it's
it's tremendous and I kind of want that
mouth it these are great starter whines
for kids yeah really good kids hooked on
this first good gnarly seriously
[Music]